[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là on retient que la victoire on est en
demi-finale on est super content tout le
monde est super content on a fait
quelque chose d'historique qui est pas
arrivé depuis très longtemps et on va
bien profiter et on va se remettre au
travail d demain pour la demi-finale
c'est c'est un grand pas vers l'avant
c'est historique j'espère que tout le
monde continue à être fier de nous et
que tout le monde va continuer à nous
encourager je pense qu'on a eu la
victoire qu'on méritait au bon moment
par ça fait c'est vrai qu'on avait passé
les tours et voilà plus important comme
je disais c'est de continuer la route ça
pas été facile aujourd'hui contre une
belle équipe de Guinée qui nous a posé
quelques problèmes tactiques mais les
garçons ont été assez sobres même après
avoir été mené on sait pas pas folé on a
joué notre football et et puis et puis
voilà moi je me rappelle quand on est
arrivé ici on où les premiers discours
du coach c'était de remettre le Congo à
sa place en tant que grande nation du
football et avec la détermination la
concentration et la rigueur on est en
train d'y arriver petit à petit ça
montre qu'on progresse de match en match
je pense que le coach il fait toujours
le meilleur pour l'équipe il fait les
choix en fonction de en fonction de
l'équipe avant tout et donc faut penser
collectif là on est dans une compétition
internationale on va aller jusqu'au bout
et c'est la mentalité qu'il faut avoir
dès qu'il finit tu dégages
ton